rosie is with us in El Paso Texas hi
Rosie how are you hi did I'm doing great
so I just wanted to let you know I'm
getting an injury
yeah and fighting I followed all of this
got myself out of debt and the cash flow
the wedding which cost thirteen thousand
so we did babysit her phone is going all
over the place can you speak directly
into it please oh I'm so sorry can you
hear me now yes ma'am thank you okay
sorry let me start from the beginning so
long you've got 13 thousand for a
wedding that's coming in June we got
that right okay so we had a fully funded
baby step and he was just like you said
when Murphy comes Murphy comes it was
just emergency after emergency after
emergency which brought our fully funded
emergency funds of 10,000 all the way
down to 500 and so we have three checks
until the wedding and from those three
checks we can save six thousand but so
we there's a couple things that we
wanted to get for the wedding like
wedding favors and because it's the
destination wedding we also were
thinking about like maybe having a nice
dinner with everyone or providing
another form of entertainment this will
all be there for three days and so our
question is yes we know we need to bring
the emergency fund up to a thousand but
do we do we can we forget all the extra
stuff and just put it towards the
emergency funds or should we just have
you had nine thousand five minutes
recently at nine thousand five hundred
dollars worth of emergencies yeah I can
tell you exactly what happened it was I
have a high deductible and so from the
emergencies the things that happened was
I had an ambulance bill which was two
thousand dollars I ended up having some
emergency dental work so it was
emergencies between the both of us and
then worst of all this is gonna sound
absolutely crazy but I almost killed my
fiance's dog and I felt responsible and
so I actually took on those those
emergencies from our emergency account
that's right
so what happens if you have an emergency
and you have paid for a dinner at the
wedding and you have no money well
that's what I'm thinking is I guess
maybe we shouldn't do those extra things
well are some of them but maybe not all
of them would I buy luxury add-ons to
the wedding when I only have one
thousand dollars to my name no and the
reason is what has happened to you in
the past year things like a matter of
three months if you hadn't had an
umbrella when it rained
you'd be all wet yeah I don't that's why
I think umbrellas are good yeah so I
mean I'm not trying to be like a kilt
you know like Dave hates weddings Dave
doesn't hate weddings I love weddings
are three weddings we had with our three
kids were huge parties we we party man
we love it we think celebrate our butts
off man we have a good time and but but
so I want you to do all that but I'm
just don't also don't want you to get
you know get your block knocked off
kiddo all right
I mean cuz sighs you know stuff happen
stuff happens
stuff happens if you don't have money
it's a problem right right right
so it may be five thousand and maybe you
do a little bit of you know you get
halfway rebuilt and and you know you
work some overtime or y'all do some
other stuff and you know in order to do
a few things at the wedding but am I
gonna have you do wedding add-ons with a
thousand dollars in the bank
why you should you wouldn't advise
someone to do that based on what has
happened to you in the last four months
why would you leave yourself exposed
after what you've just been through it's
just not logical